hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round five of
the 2022 tata still masters it's a
richard rapport versus aramis babu
pragyananda and it really shows how one
move can make all the difference as
you'll see in this game let's check it
out raport with the white pieces uh
opens with d4 uh sorry about that
uh
uh we have knight to f6 by prague c4 we
have e6 knight the c3 and the bishop to
b4 so already a very exciting ninja
indian defense is on the board
uh sorry about that uh we have queen to
c2 uh going for for the classical line
this is the most popular move queen the
c2 and the e3 are amongst the most
popular we have castles and now a3
challenging the bishop on b4 that we
have bishop captures on c3 and now as
you've developed the queen to c2 you
don't have to mess up your pawn
structure
you can recapture with the queen and now
b6 is again by far the most popular you
want to get to the bishop over to this
long diagonal
but uh prague goes for the immediate d5
so here bishop to g5 putting pressure on
the knight so the knight can't move now
and now c5 so again incredibly sharp
offering this pawn to to get some a very
nice counter play with pawn to d4 so uh
rapport accepts this with d captures on
c5 uh and d4 now uh attacking the queen
we have queen all the way to g3 here you
could make a lot of queen
retreats queen to
uh to f3 queen to g3 you could play
queen to c2 queen
pretty much anywhere queen to g3 is what
rapper goes for and now knight b to d7
you have to be very careful uh your
queen ever moves from the defense of the
knight it's pretty much game over so we
have to add another defender to the
knight here and now knight to f3 uh
continuing development with e5 now
offering this pawn and well the the
position has been reached before knight
captures an e5 is a known move for
example if knight captures e5 knight
captures on c5 the game just continues
also e3 is a known move challenging
black strong
set up here in the center but rapport
just plays a rook to d1 and it is now as
of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game uh so how can uh prague
continue here he plays rook to e8 adds
more support to the night now e4 is uh
well one one of the ideas uh and the
rapper just uh boldly defends the c5
pawn he plays b4 and says i can keep my
king in the center the king is safe on
e1 and i will uh
defend my my extra pawn so now he's up
upon and prague has to prove that uh
well the pawn sacrifice was worth it so
here he strikes uh at the pawn chain
with a5 he wants to play a captures on
b4 and now knight to d2 getting more
control over this e4 square so knight to
e4 will put a lot of pressure on this
knight here a captures on b4 we have
eight captures and now uh how do you
continue with black well you should
continue with pawn to e4 definitely
makes sense now the knight can come to
e4 the rook defends this uh and uh it's
just a
tough position for for white to handle
but i guess the the pressure was too
much for prague with the the constant
worry about moves like bishop here
bishop here so he played king to a fate
now he doesn't have to worry about such
things anymore but uh he also uh misses
his opportunity to to advance those
pawns so here we have queen to b3
uh and the queen to b3 is a move that um
well it is hard to understand for one
you don't really expect
to play g3 and bishop to g2 because if
g3 then we can just play h6 and then
white has to give up the bishop because
if you go h4 g5 traps the bishop there's
a pawn on g3
another thing is okay maybe uh if the
the pawns really advance forward maybe
era
saw all of this uh and maybe he's
planning to put a queen on this diagonal
to just control it so that might be the
idea behind queen to b3 but other than
this it's not um
very easy to to understand the move so
here h6 we have bishop back to h4 and
now pawn to e4 uh sorry pawn to e4 by
black grabbing a lot of space here and
now of course like we said g3 g5 just
drops the bishop so here we have e3 and
now prague has to really be precise with
his moves here he advances the pawn to
d3 and who wouldn't it's such a such a
pleasant move to make you completely
stifle white you say okay you're not
moving anything here you can't develop
the bishop uh how are you how are you
ever developing anything here if you
ever play g3 just g5 perhaps the bishop
so uh this must be good for black
however knight to e5 was much much
stronger because now white is really
without any moves
there's nothing you can play here and if
you try something like knight captures
on e4 as the knight is pinned we just
play g5 we on pin and after let's say
knight d6 going after the rook uh we can
just capture on h4 for example knight
captures queen captures but this will be
much better for black so it seems that
this is the moment where you don't go
forward where you just prepare you play
knight to e5 you still give why the move
and d3 is always an option but okay d3
was played and now we have h3 uh we have
g5 attacking the bishop bishop to g3 and
knights the e5 but now it's a little bit
different because now queen to b2 and
what we've discussed now the queen
controls this diagonal and it's not so
pleasant the knight here is hanging now
so queen to e7 prague defense and now uh
rook to a1 attacking the undefended rook
on a8 so here prague captures we have
rook captures queen captures and now
bishop to f5 uh continuing development
but now uh bishop captures an e5 and
here you see that white's uh problem no
longer exists because white's biggest
issue with the position was
that he doesn't have moves and there are
still so many pieces on the board of
queens are on the board black is
attacking white white should get crushed
however
here he just allowed rapper to to trade
off everything
bishop captures queen captures queen
captures rook captures and now he plays
g4 uh we have bishop to g6 and now
bishop to g2 and now he can even castle
and get the rook into the game
or even push the f pawn by king f2 there
are many ideas you can move the knight
play king to d2 uh all depends on what
black plays so here black wants to make
use of the only open file on the board
that is the a file and he plays rook to
e8 he wants to play rook to a8 and try
and do some damage here so here knight
to b1 making room for the king now comes
knight to d7 we have king to d2 now
comes rook to a8 and here just king to
c3 and now the uh real question is how
do you deal with rook to a2 because uh
your black will go after the f2 pawn and
white's biggest advantage is that he's
he is up upon
but it would seem that that's not
white's only advantage white's other
advantage is the extremely active king
and the three to one advantage uh
well pawn wise on the queen side so here
we have rook to a2 going after the pawn
but white just plays rook to d1 he says
all right you you can have your pawn i i
don't really mind so rook captures on f2
was played and now comes rook to d2
defending the bishop and offering a rook
trade and now of course uh uh prague
doesn't want to trade rooks as those
pawns are incredibly scary so he keeps
the rooks on the board and now king to
d4 you have to be very active with the
king we have rook to e6 adding a
defender to the e4 pawn and now knight
to c3
just putting
more pieces into the center of the board
and now we have knight to f6 now
interestingly if you try knight the v8
to go for some sort of a knight to c6
check because it really does seem like
you could maybe check made the white
king just b5 and we don't really care
about that knight on b8 anymore so after
knight to c3 knight to f6 was played
adding another defender here
and now just b5 and now well black has
to be very very careful we are creating
a pass the pass pawn at some point king
to g7 now comes rook to a2 now we're
hoping to even pick up this pawn so here
h5 we have g captures on h5 and now
bishop to f5 still keeping an eye on
this pawn and white's white's double
pawns and the h file will be less of an
issue now so rook to b2
uh
preparing to play c6 now and if b
captures on c6 just start advancing our
past pawn because we already have a rook
here uh if you go rook to a7 it's also
possible i mean
it should be winning uh there shouldn't
be anything black can do about this but
this is also a viable plan so king to h6
blocking the pawn now also preparing to
capture it and now rook to f2 attacking
the undefended bishop bishop to h7
and now comes knight to d5 also
interestingly uh rook captures on f6 is
also winning white is so active with the
king that pretty much any movie in the
position is winning for example captures
we're going to play captures characters
captures and you're just much much
better now rookie six king captures on
d3 you have so much uh so much more uh
uh pressure you know it's impossible for
for black to handle everything so after
bishop to h7 we have knight to d5 and
now knight captures on h5 we have rook
captures on f7 and now the very tricky
pawn to d2 now prague is threatening
pawn to d1 and there is only one good
way to prevent pawn to d1 and even feel
free to pause the video here and try to
figure out how would you do it while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always moving the
knight back knights to c3 is the correct
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show uh yeah knight to c3
but for those of you who found rook to
f1 that's a terrible move because
black just plays knight to g3 attacks
your rook and once you move the rook
knights to e2 is checkmate
that's very unfortunate the knight
blocks the c3 square this is blocked by
the pawn this is blocked by the rook and
you just got checkmated so after knight
g3 you're not going to be able to move
the rook you're going to have to play
something else and give up that rook and
black will just win the game so tonight
the c3 is in fact the only winning
continuation for white uh we have
knights to g3 now
again hoping for some tricks here for
example if rook captures on b7 we can
play knight to e to check and now uh you
either move the king and lose the knight
or you capture the knight and black gets
the queen into the game so again you
have to be very careful rapper plays a
knight to d1 this is again the absolute
best knight to e2 check and now king to
d5 advancing even further attacking the
rook rook to e8 and now king to d6 very
very impressive uh king activity with
bishop to g6 attacking the rook just
rook to d7
knights to f4 now attacking the bishop
asking wha what do you do with the
bishop and uh well uh rapper just
doesn't care he plays king to c7 he
wants to grab this pawn and then advance
his past pawns uh the bishop isn't all
that
important so here uh knight captures and
g2 is played you really don't have
anything better now rook captures on d2
you remove this uh pass pawn so black is
uh
really without any counter play here
knight to e1 and now king captures on b7
and now those phones are unstoppable
knights to d3 c6 is uh here bishop to f5
guarding the queening square but it
doesn't matter c7 the b pawn will help
out as well rook to e5 now uh and here
knight b to d2 now sorry knight to b2 we
have knight to c five with check king to
c6 and now knight to b3 uh we've rooked
to d8 regarding um sorry rook to d8 uh
preparing to queen the pawn but really
just preparing to push the beep on rook
to c5 check king to d6 and now we have
g4 uh it doesn't really do anything but
you have to play something bishop
captures now comes b6 and he was in this
position on move 56 that uh pragananda
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh you can't move
the knight because you lose the rook the
rook or can't really move the rook has
to keep an eye on this the bishop is a
light square bishop so nothing to you
you can do there the king completely
inactive for for for most of the game so
completely winning for wide just b7 b8
and that's it black can resign uh but of
course he was in this position that
prague resigned and this means that
rapper not only wins the game but also
joins the leaders as these are the
standings after five rounds of the tata
still 2022 so the leader
uh
sorry i i believe these are the old
rankings for some reason uh
let me just check
what oh okay i must have uh saved it
somewhere else let me just uh fix this
real quickly
oh yeah i saved it to a different folder
uh silly me all right
sorry about that
there we go
all right so these are the new standings
uh so as you can see with three and a
half points we have uh mamidarov
and rapport um uh so currently in the
lead uh then with three points yes panko
and carlson with two and a half points
youngshi duda fabiano caruana and fun
forest uh with two points uh giri dubov
uh shankland uh karyakin and prague here
and niels gandelius still on one point
with uh which with the true two draws he
got uh one against the magnus cross in
the game that we've shown yesterday so
if you see who's playing in the
tournament uh you know names like giri
dubo of karjakin uh caruana
i mean those are uh carlson and those
are incredible names but none of them
are leading leading uh players are
mamadara with it and they're upwards so
it's a crazy tournament anything can
happen and anyone can win uh as we've
seen last year when uh fun forest
won the entire event uh so yeah and
that's the game those were the standings
hope you guys enjoyed it really
impressive game uh and it really uh
shows how for example here this was uh
really really crazy where uh this d3
move was played so just 95 and the white
is really without a move it's very very
difficult to parry all the threads that
black has but once you advance this pawn
and it seems like such a crushing
stifling idea you actually help white
develop so unfortunately for prague
that's how chess sometimes works uh and
uh when you have a position like this so
you know don't just rush with a move
like pawn to d3 consider other moves as
well uh so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed
that i would like to thank matthew
valdez uh mohan churulandi uh malaki
havahan ron swanson and tom earl for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event
until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day